my name is Margaret Avery and I am the
member for Walden Field ward and the
cabinet member for Communities I was
elected in May 2015 my days are very
flexible and can change at late notice
sometimes I start at 7:00 in the morning
I leave home and I don't arrive back
until late at night the meetings can be
very variable sometimes I can have
meetings all days sometimes I can have
one in the morning one in the afternoon
and one in the evening and that's one of
the things that I enjoy about being in
capsular it's not 9:00 to 5:00 I was
just asked if I would if I would stand I
had to think about it because I was
concerned about time whether I would
like to be pinned down from 9:00 to 5:00
but I was assured it wasn't like that
and I can guarantee it isn't if you are
really interested in democracy then you
should stand to be a counselor it is no
point complaining to account solar water
to your parish to your district to your
County if you have an opinion and you
have never bought
and if you are really serious about
helping others being involved then
standing for council is for you it's 90
years since the act of equal
representation which gave men and women
equal opportunity to vote we are so also
celebrating the hundredth anniversary of
when the first women had the vote next
year we have district council elections
and it would be really good to see more
women coming forward to stand for these
positions there there are always people
who can advise and who can who can help
and if you don't step forward then there
won't be women in politics in the future